hey ich hab mein mikro etwas mal zwei
karten
ja ja ja jetzt willkommen zu einer neuen
folge der pick up web zusammen mit fans
und mit gott und meiner persönlichkeit
wird hier stinkt mir bei den b hin netz
den sprung in ganz minecraft faktor
sprünge und conny hat mich das schon
einmal in der letzten folge beim runter
geschlagen am ende mit dem schneeball
was habt ihr das gesehen oder 123 123 12
12 x l 312 waren zwei drei stunden
schaffen was immer mit 12 geht es auch
noch nicht geweint 2 1 2 1 2 1 2 1 2
geschafft
du bist der boss vossloh pro haft alter
und jetzt
yoga weg mit dir ja okay ich bete für
die hardter beobachtung von dana ich
hab's geschafft alter zum ersten mal
diese scheiß taktisch rücke 1212 kuwait
seine fans auf video denn die stadt auch
immer du so alt wie ich dich gerade
schaut und wären dann von mir mit
bananen abgewartet hälfte geschafft
hatte wartet wartet mal alter halt dein
maul ich hätte nicht mit kisten
oh nein ich will keine mängel
da schaue ich mir an was ich in der hand
halte alter macht dass schneebälle komme
du konntest dich nicht alter weißt was
ich gern hab im boden junge geil alter
trading kann beginnen du affe du penner
nein
komm hier um pure alter wie das komische
kopf aufwartet guck ich mir bitte ganz
kurz an ich habe auch nichts an
okay okay ich gut es ist gute ware so
wir müssen jetzt irgendwo entlang
gesamten erst mal hier rein gehen oder
hier in den kleinen tempel oder was das
auch immer hier ist und dann mal schauen
ob wir hier hier hier lang
da kommt noch richtig viel ja wahlalter
ultimate rolle walter ich bin oben drauf
macht das training spaß junge ich dachte
schon er finde es einfach 8 in einer
kiste
sie haben zusammen nicht machte der
kompletten map bisher gefunden es stimmt
wir insgesamt sieben mal gut erzählt
komme gut gezielt solche wir geräusche
frage oder alle mathelehrer gommel der
kontakte zwischen alter der mutter macht
sich sorgen
dass selbst ein mikro genommen ans
fenster gestellt oder wiegen
nein ich hab mein mikro etwas direkter
als feuerwehr
das war ein polizei sind wir wieder hier
unten affe
und ich mache jetzt einfach so weil dort
nicht kaffee
mai an das gibt es doch nicht so ich bin
jetzt auf rage sowie wie geht's denn
hier weiter so ich bin in der kleinen
kammer da kann man nicht viel machen
wir können die hände weiter springt hier
haben wir auch noch klappen aber wie
kommen wir hier hoch das ist mal wie
eine frage die ich dir stande weil du
dich ja man damit immer gut auskennt wie
man denn da hoch kommt wie man einen
hochkriecht meinst du da kann man nicht
hoch das soll möglichst unmöglich jetzt
zwei leitern was euch doch der weg gas
trainerin und ja dann plötzlich hier auf
jeden fall schon meine leitet so einfach
direkt
und jetzt träumt ja hier verstehen da
drüben maker checkpoint toto-lotto die
leinwand für da vorne
guck mal
hallo leute ich hatte mal werde ich
getötet
nein nein für am anfang der karte dich
zu mir ich gut gemacht kommen ich
erwarte ich muss mal schauen ich mach
das mal einer kommt ist ein euro pro
person
ja du wolltest gebohrt werden habe ich
gehört ja okay du musst ja bescheiden
sagt wenn du wolltest
ich bring dich um warten warten warten
warten vor springt das kann am ende kein
break green red wolle okay ich kann nur
davor rote wolle kaputt machen
hier ist eine rote wolle know jack bauer
hier ist eine rote wollen wasser und ich
schlage und die schlager und ich schlage
und ich schlage die kapo
was war drin also check point so ich
habe jetzt auf den jackpot drauf
geklickt wo ok oh geil dass wir gut aus
wie komme ich hier hoch wie komme ich da
hoch schnell nein ich kann von hier
nicht sehr hoch no secret no point ich
hab ne kiste gefunden und einfach mal
nichts drin da steht so kann man hier
eine kiste wein hätten zeigt seine fans
kam jack ist also nächste punktemäßig
scheiße da man einfach nicht drin
ich habe eine angel com redet einfach
gar nicht mehr mit mir denn macht
einfach nur sein ding ja ich bin leicht
angesäuert weil du hand wieder punkte
gefunden hast
ich habe zwei und du hast schon sieben
mal warum müsst ihr also so bösen zu
erstehen zu mussten fischangebot den
rhein werfen einfach wolle reingeworfen
es geht auch auf dann hier
du musst hier reinkommen ja ich hab eine
gastrede gefunden
vogel ja in die halb du kannst dich
schon ausruhen
du bist schon hier er sagte ja geil
bommel glich jo weil wir man sagen der
verlierer musste strafe immer nein ja
klar
das wollten wir letzte karte auch schon
machen
da hab ich gewonnen sagen wir bei der
nächsten karte das kannst du sogar noch
ankommen freunde habe ich das gesagt
oder nicht nein
nein nein nein also dass die kommentare
ob ich das gesagt habe aber nicht ja und
wenn schon wir haben ja bei decca sie
nicht von anfang an gesagt dass es dann
eine strafe gibt weil dann wenn man
natürlich hoffe ich auch viel mehr nach
punkten aus wenn ich danach dann wenn
ich wüsste okay wenn ich verliere hier
dann muss ich eine strafe machen dann
würde ich mich anstrengen und hätte dich
schon lange vernichtet
kollege checkpoint vom klima her
wieso sie so lange hier land nein von da
komme ich doch von da ja von den leitern
wir müssen da irgendwie auf die andere
seite habe ich weiß nicht wie ich hab
noch leiter oder ehrlich wenn ich glaube
man muss ja auch so ein haus herum
muss man sogar und cheeseburger sodann
dann mal hier hoch so da war nur
phishing rotz drin alter ja da war ich
auch schon dran
er hasste das redstone rausgenommen der
lässt es richtig liegen wird dann war
ich da noch nicht dran
ach nee das habe ich da rein gelegt aber
das album 4 welt mitgenommen
danke war halt dein maul controlling
sachen so schneebälle phishing rott und
so was alles eine angel investor ist als
kritisch
so aber wie machen wir hier weiter auf
die andere seite kommt hast du dich noch
eine leiter oder so ich habe es
geschafft
ja du bist geflogen ja grad mal geschaut
ob rango hier muss mich gilt aber sowas
von keine bruno braun teil
ja ich habe ja komm mit komm mit acht
hier geht es da kommt man sagt ja immer
die angel weg fast nichts angel tropfen
einfach geil
richtig gehandelt j.lo checkpoint und
nun ihr geht es hier weiter
ich habe keine ahnung
komme ich weiß sie dass mit dem
checkpoint funktioniert wenn du offenen
checkpoint drauf drückt dann spawnen
beide an dem punkt wo der letzte auf den
wo sie halt standen als man auf den
checkpoint gedrückt hat weil ich stand
gerade bei der leiter habe ich dann
umgebracht und kurz nachdem du auf den
scheck von gedrückt und ich bin direkt
wieder neben der leiter gespannt das
heißt immer als duo auf den checkpoint
gedrückt hass auf 9 bin ich irgendwo
anders gespannt wo ich stehen geblieben
bin verstehst du ja ja hier geht es
weiter verstehst du halt dein maul hier
hier an der seite
okay okay bin ich ja jetzt porte mich du
hast schon mutter geschummelt
ohne spaß da fliege ich hoch ich hab
keinen bock das nochmals neu zu machen
trololo liegt dir nur um orte mich erst
dann dann dann las ich sein wenn du mich
darauf gebracht hat
mein okay okay okay und survival weiter
zum einfach nichts zu machen
willst du heute warte warte bitteschön
wow wow ich mache hier mal weiter in
aller ruhe man es will ich wieder
gefragt ob ich mir meine chance ich bin
eigentlich bin gefangen
ich komme nicht aus ich bin ich bin echt
gefangen wie geht das denn bitteschön ja
kommt kommt dir das an geilmann respekt
warum mich wenn du mich darunter gelegt
hast ja aber du mich dreimal sch ich
mache dich these dass etabliert nein ich
hätte ich fast noch darunter gekickt
jetzt sofort es mich jetzt duport ist
nicht komme du hast dich da zweimal
runter geschlagen kik von kraft wie er
sich freut wenn du einfach an den rand
los wir müssen produktiver werden hier
müssen das nochmal schaffen wir den
abteilen und bamm bamm bamm
scheiße scheiße scheiße was stehen hier
des wunders classic h
ich habe es geschafft checkpoint 2 darf
ich dich pforten
nein ok so was stand da drauf hast du da
bist du auch respekt hat herr stolz war
ernst gemeint wirklich conference hall
checkpoint cook und ich schwöre dir
douze points ist nicht mal wenn es gibt
da wo du gerade gestanden hast auf dem
blog wahrscheinlich eher auf dem blog
stehen minecraft es kommt oft ich bleibe
im block drin du tust bei uns davor wie
dr
wahrscheinlich geht das bei mir nicht
angenommen weil ich keine op bin
das können sogar sein komm vorbei ist
okay ich hab ja danke bitte so wartet
das schaffen wir noch kom kom kom
nein
der geht einfach raus und treuen mit die
folge ist er vorbei leute wenn euch
gefallen hat mich meine freundin ist
erfolges morgen bei dem schlawiner hier
bei diesem schmarotzer oft im kanal und
dann sehen wir uns morgen wieder